big news this weekend the migrant
Caravan actually exists it's right
across the US border and t-one in Mexico
causing huge problems for that city that
may be a surprise to you because you've
been hearing for weeks and weeks that
the caravan wasn't real you'd have to be
a right-wing bigot to think it was then
they told you it's so far away that it's
irrelevant well then on Sunday that
irrelevant imaginary migrant Caravan
attacked American border guards and that
may surprise you more still because you
were told the caravan was entirely
harmless and again if you believe
otherwise you're a bad person well soon
a news story we don't know what it is
but we can be sure there is one will
come to dominate the headlines in the
migrant caravan will be mostly forgotten
even if the border crisis remains
unresolved the press the public likely
the president too will have moved on but
we want to pause just for a moment
before that happens that inevitably
happens and look back and consider how
this story was handled by the press
because we think it matters now the
story evolved rapidly and the media's
official story evolved just as rapidly
but were there descriptions about what
was happening factually on the ground
true tonight we want to investigate that
this is not a partisan question by the
way it's about the future of the country
for a free society to function the press
doesn't have to be perfect but it does
have to be better than a propaganda
outlet are they let's break it down with
buck Sexton
he's a former CIA analyst and host of
the buck Sexton show and he joins us
tonight buck thanks a lot for coming on
you've been following this really
closely you had the really I thought
incisive breakdown of the coverage and
so I want to put these questions to you
this is claim number one the migrant
Caravan we were told is mostly women and
children who pose no threat to anybody
here's one example of that claim all of
this for a group of people a lot of whom
are mothers and children who pose no
imminent threat to the United States
many of these individual
women and children oh the talking point
you remember was it true no in fact a
vast majority of them are clearly what
we would have called in the agency
military age males these are guys mostly
in their 20s and 30s and that was a
parent Tucker I mean there are the there
the misreporting that you could expect
from people making an honest mistake and
then there's a lot of journalists
gathered together because I've been
talking to journalists all throughout
this caravans progression and there's
just been this march of lies there have
been some people telling the truth but
all they do is be there and you see it's
guys this is mostly guys there are some
women children there but the focus on it
is clearly dishonest of course claim
number two the caravan we were told
again and again is mostly comprised of
genuine asylum seekers seeking refuge in
the u.s. these people are coming and
asking for asylum guess what man it's in
our laws that people are allowed to come
to our borders and ask for asylum yeah
it's our fault for not welcoming them
because they're sincere asylum seekers
is that true
no it's a scam and people know it's a
scam based on the percentage of
individuals in the past who have come
and tried to claim asylum in this way
and the fact that they're being coached
to lie this is actually a form of fraud
when you say that I'm an imminent fear
of my life because people along the way
have said this is what you have to say
to get into the asylum process you can
later be adjudicated
you're lying to people in a vast
majority of these cases and by the way
if just being from Honduras for example
means you're in such sort of violence
that you can get asylum then the whole
country would qualify for asylum so this
is a scam and people realize that now
but the meeting was pretending all along
that it is not that is such a good point
why doesn't the whole country qualify
for some I'm surely here sooner than it
does claim number three there are no
criminals in this Caravan I spent two
days with a caravan and I didn't see
criminals or rapists or terrorists stop
saying they're monsters there are more
mothers than monsters how did the dumb
people get on TV but they do it was that
true there are no criminals there are
more mothers than monsters an official
statement yesterday from immigration and
customs enforcement says about 600 known
criminals by the way so these are people
that we are we are sure have a criminal
record apart from trying to cross the
border and perhaps throw some rocks at
some federal agents and
by the way I'm ever speaking to a
journalist early on this talker said
pretty sure there are some criminals
because there are a whole bunch of guys
covered in ms-13 tattoos which are very
prominent who are marching along with
the caravan - so this was known from the
beginning but people chose to focus on
other things
were they ms-13 mothers not monsters or
were they meant I suppose that's
possible but certainly the media was
trying to find a way to avoid the fact
that there were some bad folks among
this whole crew they were lying claim
number four and this comes from a former
commander in chief the caravan doesn't
matter and you're a bad person for
worrying about it because it's very far
away there's a bunch of refugees of
their way down there we don't even know
where they are buck buses and trains
exist in Mexico which I think
journalists know especially journalists
who are in Mexico
reporting on this but there was always
this well it's going to take them
forever to march know what they did is
they by the way with some help God on
buses trains other modes of
transportation got through the border by
the way if they were actually refugees
as Obama says they should claim refugee
status in the first country they arrived
in where they are no longer under mortal
threat Mexico has offered them asylum
they've said no because they're not
refugees they are just people that want
to get the frontline for immigration
such a great point Jorge Ramos who
Univision came on this program to
present claim number five that the
caravan received no external support I
know that there are fake stories seen in
the United States saying that these
people were funded by your Soros and by
Democrats or by Nicolas Maduro from
Venezuela if they really find out these
people it was a scam I've been talking
to people here in Chiapas we don't have
a single dollar talker to buy a bottle
of water so there's no financing here no
financing at all and by the way you're
amoral if you claim otherwise that's a
lie I've talked to journalists you are
seeing people handing out food gathering
donations together so they can buy food
and equipment when you got six seven
thousand people together that's going to
be a difficult logistical challenge
unless there are people who are there to
provide support and there
our people to providing support so again
the journalist wanted to know this stuff
talker some of them do but they just
don't get as much airtime in places like
CNN and MSNBC they could find out but
they don't want to know they just want
to present people getting to your gas
mothers and children if you don't like
this you're a monster when the reality
is this is a massive scam there's a lot
of outside help and there are laws that
are being broken here and finally we
have the sixth claim that deploying
troops to the border was wrong but it
was also completely unnecessary as a New
York Times cartoonist put it troops sign
up to fight in an obscure country in the
Middle East not to guard their own
country's border Kamla Harris agreed
with that it is inappropriate to require
the limited resources of the United
States military to be used in such a way
all because there needed to be some
demonstration for the TV cameras based
on a political agenda instead of what is
a national security threat so why aren't
they in Syria where they belong
also why can't senator Harris call down
to border patrol and say or immigration
and customs enforcement that matter or
do you think it's helpful because the
answer is yes because I've spoken to
border patrol and they say that the
logistical support that military was
giving them was in fact very much needed
because this Caravan was arriving and
there were real concerns that they were
trying to over on the border which
Tucker is exactly what they did do so
we've just had this progression of lies
all along the way and at every phase it
seems the media always gets it wrong in
one direction and that is somehow we're
exaggerating this threat when in fact
we're under estimating the reality of
how big this problem is gonna get a
precise fact-based summation and we're
grateful for it buck Saxon thank you
very much good to see you Tucker